i'm gonna do an open challenge
for my youtube intercontinental
championship uh oh
i'm challenging anybody
in the youtube world jj
go get that title it'll be one of those
you already have it jay oh it's perfect
jj it's just perfect jj is on d live
jade it'll be one of those d live
invasions the colors are already right
too like the nxt invasion
you're going to invade and i want you to
get that title let's do it
jj let's set this up you're gonna go and
we're gonna have a match
it's gonna be amazing dustin's really
good at selling and stuff
in the youtube world if anybody has the
ghost to come after
my youtube intercontinental champion
he's talking to you jj
come and get it
i'm the youtube intercontinental
champion because i'm
the best in the world
yes that's what i do yes i'm even
open a challenging
day way radio for my
youtube intercontinental championship
what did you say dustin
is he calling me out is he calling me
out
he's calling me out
oh boy dustin oh you don't want any of
this dustin
even i'm open and challenged to my
zombie squad
anybody who wants to challenge me for
the youtube
intercontinental championship
time the time is
yes sir i know you're not gonna take
that line down are you this let me tell
you something jj let me
let me tell you something brother
he's going to show up
and he is going to challenge me the man
who's been
the man who brought him out the man who
brought him out of ohio valley wrestling
into the [ __ ]
in in into the main stage he's gonna
come after me
someone's getting a little too big for
their skirt
uh it's it's a shame 14.
god damn it it's ticking guys
leave a comment down below how many of
y'all wants a shot
at my intercontinental youtube
championship i do i'm waiting
just bring it
leave a comment down below guys who
wants
a shot at my intercontinental
youtube championship it's an open
challenge oh
boy give me your best shot
my fellow youtubers because
when it's time for baby i'm opening a
challenge
for the intercontinental youtube
championship
leave a comment down below who wants it
more
dustin's signing off on youtube as your
youtube intercontinental champion
first off i'm a main eventer but i'll
[ __ ] slum it for the intercontinental
belt just to teach you a [ __ ] lesson
all right i should be going for the main
dub for the main youtube title not the
intercontinental title okay the world
title
but you know what that's fine i'll go
down
and i'll take you out dustin you're
coming at me you're coming at me like
that is that what you want you want some
of this bud
let's see what happens in your house
this sunday and not the pay-per-view
i'll go to your house
oh dustin oh dustin dustin dustin dustin
dustin
i'm not gonna do the job for you either
i like you bud but i'm gonna win
i'm gonna take that i'll shake your hand
afterwards but i'm taking that title
it's gonna be
mine
some of this for me dustin i don't think
so buddy
i don't [ __ ] think so buddy